the Joe Rogan experience those are the
same people that are injecting Lysol
right now they aren't so you know well
somebody might it's probably a few yeah
well you know if you're gonna what about
how chloroquine thing you know the one
form of chloroquine that was but the the
form that was a pond cleaner
oh yeah husband but here's the thing the
lady wasn't she like a democratic
contributor and donor she needed that
Donald Trump was a psycho that and and
her and her husband took the stuff well
there's new reporting that says the
husband was an engineer his friends are
shocked that he would do something so
stupid so the wife poison him that's the
theory that's going around now now the
the fair point brought up I think it was
a free weekend is that he trusted his
wife and he loved her Wow when I shoot
him poor she's really dumb but
apparently a couple decades ago she had
struck him there's a report about it
decades ago yeah 20 years I think but
there's also reports and you got
affected this stuff for sure because
it's not like something I've been diving
too much too deep into but she was
trying to divorce the guy so the story
popping up is that the owner Carol
Baskin of chloroquine that's what people
have been saying yeah like the rumors
going around but whether or not any
that's true it's like you know I always
say give me the proof but I can't tell
you this the media loves to run
everything the president says through a
filter of like it must be taken
literally or to its worst most the
opposite have benefited out the most
negative conclusion possible hmm if he
says it we're gonna run the most
negative interpretation it's bad it's
awful you know so when he says something
like you know that that Peter Navarro
instance where he said you know you're
nasty reporter he said about
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine it
might work it might not but I'm
optimistic what did the press run with
trump recommends untested dangerous drug
meanwhile you getting scrupulous Proust
no no press room with that right right
of course
but but look when Andrew Cuomo came out
and said we're gonna start trying you
know chloroquine hydroxychloroquine and
as a therm Ison where was the negative
press didn't they say that that has
actually been proved
to kill more people than not using it
though the six yeah one of the initial
stories to come and said that it was
actually more likely to kill so the CDC
had listed that this was actual
treatment used by many countries and we
have there's a lawmaker in Michigan
she's a Democrat she was given the
treatment she had saved her life and she
personally praised the president for it
for that she's being censured and being
stripped of any I've heard of that it
sounds crazy it is it is there's a
reason why they were using it the shouts
it showed some promise with some people
I guess the idea was that the the
extreme immune system reaction in your
lungs was killing people the swelling
and the fluid buildup so by suppressing
the immune system you would stop that
from happening
the symptoms would abide and then you'd
eventually recover you know what man if
the media that there's there's a graph
showing the amount of press Obama got
versus Trump what Trump got and I think
to a certain degree Trump brought son
himself because he chased after this
press and he and he baits them and he
goes after I'm right but it's like three
or four times as much news
[Applause]